thinking about ourselves our feelings
our past our desires in our hopes is a
hugely tricky task that most of us spend
a good deal of effort trying very hard
to avoid we keep away from ourselves
because so much of what we could
discover threatens to be painful we
might find that we were in the
background deeply furious with and
resentful about certain people we were
only meant to love we might discover how
much ground there was to feel inadequate
and guilty on account of the many errors
and misjudgments we've made we might
find that though we wanted to be decent
law-abiding people we harbored fantasies
that went in appalling ly deviant and of
errant directions we might recognize how
much was nauseatingly compromised and
needed to be changed about our
relationships and our careers we don't
only have a lot to hide we are a liars
of genius it is part of the human
tragedy that we are such natural self
deceivers our techniques are multiple
and close to invisible to our worth
focusing on in particular our habit of
thinking too much and our habit of
thinking too little when we think too
much in essence we're filling our minds
with impressive ideas which blatantly
announce our intelligence to the world
but subtly ensure we won't have much
room left to rediscover long distant
feelings of ignorance or confusion upon
which the development of our
personalities may nevertheless rest we
perhaps right dense books on the role of
government bonds in the Napoleonic Wars
or publish extensively on Chaucer's
influence on the mid 19th century
Japanese novel we secure degrees from
Institutes of Advanced Study or
positions on editorial boards of
scientific journals our minds are
crammed with arcane data we can wittily
inform a dining table of guests who
wrote the entirety on epictetus or the
life and times of dogging the founder of
Zen Buddhism but we don't remember very
much at all about how life was long ago
back in the old house when father left
the mother stopped smiling and our trust
broke in pieces we deploy knowledge and
ideas that carry enormous prestige
to stand guard against the emergence of
more humble but essential knowledge from
our emotional past we bury our personal
stories beneath an avalanche of
expertise the possibility of a deeply
consequential intimate inquiry is
deliberately left to seem feeble and
superfluous next to the supposedly
grander task of addressing a conference
on political strategies of Dona Maria
the first or the lifecycle of the
Indonesian octopus we lean on the
glamour of being learn it to make sure
we won't need to learn too much that
hurts then there is our habit of
thinking too little here we pretend that
we are simpler than we actually are and
that too much psychology might be
nonsense and fuss about nothing we lean
on a version of robust common sense to
ward off intimations of our own awkward
complexity we imply that not thinking
very much is at base evidence of a
superior kind of intelligence in company
we deploy Bluff strategies of ridicule
against more complicated accounts of
human nature we sideline avenues of
personal investigation as unduly fancy
or weird implying that to lift the lid
on inner life could never be fruitful or
entirely respectable we use the
practical mood of Monday morning 9:00
a.m. to ward off complex insights of
3:00 a.m. the previous night when the
entire fabric of our existence came into
question against the backdrop of a
million stars spread like diamonds on a
mantle of black velvet deploying an
attitude of vigorous common sense we
strive to make our moments of radical
disquiet seem like aberrations
rather than the central occasions of
insight they might actually be we appeal
to the understandable longing that our
personalities be non tragic simple and
easily comprehended so as to reject the
stranger but more useful facts of our
real intricate selves a defense of
emotional honesty has nothing to do with
high-minded morality it's ultimately
cautionary and egoistic
we need to tell ourselves a little bit
more of the true
because we pay too high a price for our
lies through our self deceptions we cut
ourselves off from possibilities of
growth we shut off large portions of our
minds and end up on creative tension and
defensive while others around us have to
suffer our irritability gloom
manufactured cheerfulness or defensive
rationalizations our neglect of the
awkward sides of ourselves
buckles our very being emerging as
insomnia or impotence stuttering or
depression revenge for all the thoughts
we've been so careful not to have
self-knowledge isn't a luxury so much as
a precondition for a measure of sanity
and inner comfort
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the Bell icon
to turn on notifications
you